hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
today we have a dr. Schaefer associate
professor in Department of Biological
Sciences at the University of Notre Dame
Indiana is with us
dr. Schaefer has won several awards to
his credit over last several years I'm
going to briefly mention some of them in
2014 to 2018 he one research scholar
award from American Cancer Society in
2014 to 2017 it was the carrier catalyst
award from Susan G Komen Foundation 23rd
2011 to 2013 he was the VIII scholar
ever he won the V Scholar Award from V
foundation for cancer research 2009 to
present is the Coleman foundation
collegiate chair of cancer biology
university of notre dam 2007 to 2009 red
Christian National Research Service
about fellowship from National Cancer
Institute so he is also in the Advisory
Board of various publications and he has
also won several grants and other awards
to is Grady welcome dr. Schaefer the
science hangout thank you for having me
it's great to be here can you please
talk about yourself tell us about
yourself your background your interest
everything yeah sure I am I'm originally
from Springfield Illinois undergraduate
work here at Notre Dame and then I was a
graduate student at Duke with Sally
Horne blue and who was huh renowned for
her sort of cell cycle and cell death
studies and then I was a postdoc at
Harvard med with Joe Rudi um and where I
studied metabolism and matrix attachment
and joke
oh really well known for her studies on
breast cancer biology and then I've been
back here um I've been back here at new
per day which again was a undergrads at
alma mater expect a thousand good this
talk is about a little bit about your
mentors role models in your career yeah
i i've been really privileged to work
with to have some phenomenal and I'll
start just starting with with that warm
booth my doctoral advisor I taught me
how to be a scientist and and really the
basics of how to design experiments and
she created a lab environment that was
really dynamic for the exciting the
great to be part of and she there's no
question that she has influenced me as a
scientist tremendously and my postdoc
advisor dr. John Ruggie she really got
me more instant answers both into
biology
she is a I can't say enough about her as
I mentioned the phenomenal mentor who
cares tremendously for all of her all of
her trainees it was a really sick
village to be part of her lab and she
she just again the dynamic that were in
her lab is one of creativity one of
asking questions one where where people
feel free to exchange ideas and I was
just thrilled to be part of it
shape as fine I know you had a busy
scientist I know you have family and of
all those gates and all so tell me
please talk about your hobbies and other
things what you do other than the
research so yeah I I have a big family
I actually have five kids they range in
a
from 12 down to a newborn who's only
four months old so relieved that those
are my hobbies I spend pretty much all
of my time with my that I'm not here I'm
with my family with my wife it's and
they're amazing they're tons of fun and
and we really we always have we always
have a great time and to be honest they
really keep me balanced I think I think
everybody who's works in Sciences
understands that it's a challenging job
it's also an amazing job but it's really
amazing you know it's it's I think
really great to come home and and be
able to hang out with those guys and I
think they really balanced be it helped
me to be a better scientist by by
keeping you know always reminding me to
sort of you know maintain perspective on
day to day important so that's really
you know mine though they are my hobbies
right now question great nice to know
that and let's talk about your lab and
assess projects so one of the things
that that I really like about a place
like Notre Dame is this is just it's a
nominal graduate student community I've
had really amazing graduate students the
entire time my lab has been open about
nine years now and I've been really
fortunate to have been able different
nominal students I've had four PhDs who
are five PhD students who graduated I've
got four PhD students in the lab right
now I've got a technician and I've also
got several undergraduate students so I
really wanted to be in a place where I
could be involved in grad education I
think this is just a phenomenal place to
do it and I really I've had Domino
people in my lab from the start I'm
really lucky that that's been the case
so we have I think a really dynamic
group a lot of curiosity a lot of people
working really hard and so yeah I've
really been sort of a intentionally had
a very grad student focused lab and
since we started in 2009
and you mentioned that you got into
cancer research from your post doctor
work and also talked more about it and
maybe you eventually can get into your
presentation sure of course yeah I mean
we
I was certainly interested in cancer
when I was when I was a graduate and you
know certainly I was it was I was
personally affected as I think most
people unfortunately are but I actually
I think it was sort of a scientific
curiosity they got me into it I was
really interested in in cell death and
so that pathways when I started as their
graduate I became more in the
applications of how cancer cells will
resist or turn off cell death pathways I
got interested in that early and then
when I started my postdoctoral work I
really started to look at that in the
context of progression and also the
contributions of a ballistic felt that
pathways so on I certainly you know it's
you know again there is a certainly I
think for a lot of people were for
everybody for and but I honestly might
be betrayed my path and even the
questions I found myself drawn towards
but will be focused on understanding
cancer so please go ahead and present
your work perfect so I thought what I do
just talk a little bit about my lab more
broadly and and I thought I'd talk okay
I talked a little bit about some of the
recent data that we've got uh-huh
alright so let me just bring up my
slides
alright those up there okay yep okay so
my lab is really interested in in
understanding how cancer cells live and
die as a consequence of their status of
being attached to the extracellular
matrix we're really interested in
metabolism and how metabolism
contributes to those decisions about
whether a cell lives or dies I like to
use this as sort of a framework to
understand where we are where my lab is
in the context of studying cancer just
from the hallmarks of cancer by Doug
Hanahan and Bob Weinberg it's a you can
on you can see there's all of these
different hallmarks of cancer people are
studying people are studying a variety
of these four we are is really in the
intersection of three of these hallmarks
the first being understanding invasion
and metastasis second vision of which
again I've been studying cell death
since I was pregnant and were
fundamentally interested in
understanding the regulation of cellular
energetic so we're really interested in
speech perception of those three yeah
now again I've sort of talked about this
idea of attachment to matrix so we're
interested in cancer cells and how they
survive or die
depending on their status of whether
they are attached or not attached to
extracellular matrix and this is just a
schematic that I use often on but
extracellular matrix this is a meshwork
of proteins that are secreted by a
variety of different cell types you're
thinking about things like lemon ins and
collagen x' and most cells on through
the will utilize integral receptors to
attach to the extracellular matrix now
if they lose that attachment to the
extracellular matrix or to the ECM they
will undergo a cell death process known
as anti weakest and in a weakest is a
Greek word for homelessness so the idea
is these cells are under
program cell death as a consequence of
either undergoing important time cell
death as a consequence of losing that
attachment or departing their home so
importantly in a weakest is a caste
based dependent and so it's classical
program cell death classically pitocin
as a consequence of detachment to ECM
and as you might predict if you think
about cancer cells and the fact that
they're gonna they're going to encounter
a variety of different micro
environments during tumor progression
cancer cells typically will will will
acquire some type of resistance to to an
weakest now one of the models that we
use was initially developed by my
postdoctoral advisor John Brooke II I
mean sort of inspired by the work of
Nina Bissell where you can use em CF 10a
cells and and these are immortalized but
non tumorigenic mammary epithelial cells
so if you inject them into an animal you
will not get a tumor but you can grow
them in a fashion that causes that
allows you to study in architecture
that's relevant in the context of the
mammary gland so if you grow em CF 10a
cells in Maitre gel which is a is a
commercially available sort of matrix
preparation over time you'll get these
spherical structures here and over time
those spherical structures will hollow
out and you can use you have to sort of
imagine that you're looking at a
cross-section here like an optical
section where basically those those
those cells in the middle will die out
and you get a hollow lumen and this is
typically what you would see in the
context of the mammary gland notice that
this you see this red line here that red
line represents the basement membrane
which is made up of extracellular matrix
proteins and only those cells that are
touching the red line are attached to
the matrix are surviving so this has
become a really good model to study
matrix detachment like the cells in the
center would be induced cell death and
in a physiologically relevant context
now what's sort of interesting is if you
you can manipulate these cells you can
put in something like bcl-2 to block a
Patou psious and that blocks classical
in a weakest and what you'll get is
basically over time you'll see a
difference that's where the MCF 10a
cells will form hollow lumen and you'll
get a filled lumen when you express PCL
- and so that sort of expected bcl-2 has
shut down the ANA weakest pathway but
what's really interesting and got us
thinking about some of the work we're
doing now is that if you wait longer
those cells the ones where you have
blocked if you've blocked a Patou SACEUR
you've blocked any as those cells will
die as well and what that tells you is
that it's not enough to simply simply
block in a weakness or blocking the
ptosis in order to get cells that
survive in the woman that there has to
be some sort of alternative cell death
pathway that's clearing those cells from
the luminal space now interestingly if
you put in an oncogene like Irby - so
every two overexpressed in 25 to 30% of
all women who have breast cancer widely
studied the target of the drug Herceptin
if you do this experiment where you put
in early - it's the MCF Tenet's and you
get these you get these multi acinar
structures so again you get very
different looking structures but pay
attention here to the individual
structures where you can see now instead
of having a hollow lumen you've got
cells that are now populating the space
of these each of these individual
mammary asinine and so what that tells
us or the way that we've interpreted
this is that Irby - has some through
some downstream signaling has the
capacity to give matrix detached cells
long-term survival so it must be able to
block in a weakest and at the same time
it must be able to block this
alternative cell death process now if
you think about well what could what
could potentially be happening it turns
out that matrix detachment again what
this means is cells that that lose that
integrand mediated attachment to matrix
proteins when cells lose matrix
attachment there's actually a variety of
different cellular changes that can
so I talked about I talked about in a
weakest again in a weakest is classical
program cell death
classically Patos Asst in some contexts
it can be regulated by a down regulation
of the EGF receptor and an upregulation
of the prophetic protein bin but in
addition there's a variety of other
things that can happen as well so a
colleague of mine Mike Overholser who's
now a PI at sloan-kettering discovered a
process called an ptosis or matrix
detached cells can actually invade into
their neighbors and then can be killed
when inside of another cell and the
lysosome we've seen evidence in a
variety of different papers that there
can be changes in the differentiation
status or matrix detachment can induce
sort of a squamous like differentiation
and most importantly for what I'm going
to tell you about today is that you can
see evidence of something called AA the
G which is typically thought to be sort
of a starvation response and this is
largely work that's been done by jay
Debnath at UCSF so if we think about the
fact that matrix detachment induces
otology then this brings us to this
question that maybe these cells matrix
detachment is also a signal for some
type of changes in nutrients and how
cells utilize nutrients and what I mean
by that is if when we do these
experiments and you see our toppity
happening in matrix that have cells
we're giving these cells a full
complement of we're giving them a full
complement of meat of nutrients we're
giving them fuko's we're giving them
glutamine etc and yet they're undergoing
on top of G so this suggests that maybe
these matrix detached cells have some
sort of a deficiency in their capability
to to actually process nutrients and
this is going back to some work that I
did in Joan's lab back in 2009 but one
of the things we found is that matrix
detachment itself is a signal to
fundamentally rewire cellular metabolism
so if you follow me through this here on
the left you look at normal cells and
what I mean by normal here I mean non
cancerous cells there is a deficiency in
glucose uptake as a consequence of this
deficiency in glucose uptake you see a
limitation in flux through the pentose
phosphate pathway the pentose phosphate
pathway is critical
for the production of NADPH which is
important for regulating oxidative
stress so as you lower NADPH you get an
accumulation of reactive oxygen species
which can impact can impact energy
generation and itself cause cell death
now in contrast if you look at Irby to
transform cells so these are cells
engineered to overexpress Irby too you
can restore glucose uptake restore flux
through the pentose phosphate pathway
shown down here elevate your NADPH
production and thereby and thereby
reduce or or start to mitigate those
high levels of reactive oxygen species
which can function in a pro survival
effect to promote the survival of these
cells so again what I want you to take
away from this is that that basically
matrix detachment itself in addition to
signaling to cause in a weakest which is
caspase dependent cell death it's also a
signal to fundamentally rewire
metabolism and as a consequence of how
that metabolism is rewired you can
ultimately get changes in whether those
cells live or those cells die and really
what that leads us to is this idea that
cancer cells have to do really two
things I'm sort of oversimplifying this
but this conceptually this is a good way
I think to think about it is that cancer
cells if they encounter matrix detached
conditions they have to both block and
weakest and they have to sort of rectify
their metabolic deficiencies or rewire
their metabolism in a way that promotes
the survival and what we know is that we
know that that that sort of metabolic
rewiring and the induction of a new
weakest that those are independent of
one another these are not necessarily
these are not these are not pathways
that depend on each other so we have two
separate things going on here
we've got cancer cells needing to block
caspase dependent cell death and an
weakest and you need to rectify or
rewire your metabolism if you don't do
both of these it's not enough to give
you long term survival so we're really
interested in these questions so we're
interested in how it is that cancer
cells regulate an oasis and how is it is
that cancer cells will rewire their
fundamental question a fundamental
question that my lab is interested in so
what I thought I'd do is go through some
of our recent data today and it's really
focused on two key questions I was at
that matrix at that campus though rewire
their metabolism into what is the
mechanism by which these cells
ultimately undergo cell death if it's
independent of in a week okay so these
one of the things that we thought about
is if the cells not dying by a mitosis
then perhaps they're dying by some sort
of alternative path
potentially they're dying a necrotic
death and it's become clear over the
years
that's necrosis much like a pathologist
on that 50 genetic program and so this
work really originated with Jenny and
Juan I'm probably almost over 10 years
ago now where the the conceptual advance
was that program cell death is not just
a fad osis but rather program cell death
can include a necrotic death which was
typically thought to be sort of
accidental or incidental the term that's
been used
he was free right
and Mark really was the the main driver
of this project in the data that I'm
going to show you here today so
basically what Mark did in Philly was
asked sort of a very straightforward but
those made attachments for visible
signal to activate 4-1 and we did this a
couple of days I'm huntin left here
their help we did so that they would not
die by classic and we kissed and we
could focus fed on that Nani product or
uncanonical and we grow them and either
attack and the do the catchment
conditions what we do is we throw them
on a slates that are coated with poly
quinoa which basically forces these
cells put from defense and what you see
is here if you look at rip kinase one
there's a significant induction in her
clinic for no spells a detachment and
that replenish one is active as as
indicated by the phosphorylation Evert
minus one that's you so it looks like
the attachment itself is a signal to
food who leads the up regulates number
one and on the activation point as well
and then we moved on to the next
question being well does that of
regulation matter does that refine a
signaling actually impact the viability
of cells at and if you
if you look down here on the bottom left
this is a cell viability assay will
reproduce ten traumatic Andreea and
we're using a small molecule inhibitor
worth one I'm called neck one Decker
statin fun blocks its kinase activity
and you can see you see a significant
increase in the viability of cells to
treat with neck once and that
importantly that happens only when cells
are detached if you do this experiment
and we've sort of normalized the
viability in this case I will measure
the detached faux-fur attached viability
but if you do this in attached cells
treatment with neck one literally does
not matter does it impact the ability of
those cells to live dies
that happens only in matrix to cache so
if we in that three-dimensional culture
model that I introduced to you before
where we're looking at the ability of
cells to populate communal space for
mammary asinine you see here we've done
this experiment when we've got our MC
fna cells fitted with the DMSO control
we're treated with next one sub box trip
one tiny thing on we sort our
dimensional structure to be four
different categories and you can control
their most they're all basically storing
as clear or mostly clear
you'd sleep with neck one and now
they're scoring many of them are scoring
as fiddles are mostly build their
painfully more with some some self
populating your face you do the same
thing what cells expressing scale to and
basically this is a longer period of
time but over that time you again you'll
start to see most of those structures
eventually clear on that's shown here
and then when you treat with neck one
you now shipped two structures that are
filled or mostly filled so basically
both in our attacks versus the detached
experiments as well as our
three-dimensional culture assays you see
fundamental changes in the ability of
these cells to survive in the lumen of
these three-dimensional structures okay
so I showed you this
MGMT nacelles again I told you before
dessert these are these ourselves that
are basically they're immortalized they
but they're non-tumor genic not should
so we wanted to do similar experiments
in cancer cell lines and we actually did
this in a variety of distinct lines and
we chose things that were very different
on a pencil just to get an idea of how
broad this is her too positive to
positive
that's
mcf-7 cells which are also breast people
find and even in lines like kilos HC is
there a colon cancer line age 460 or a
lung cancer line in all of those cases
if you treat with neck once a block
kinase activity you get a bump in the
viability and that bump only happens
during when cells are clubbed that's not
just an orange skip any model also
harder cancer and I'm not going to show
you these just in the interest of time
but we we actually validated this
knockdown the first so if the concern
was potentially that the inhibitor have
seen data that were as a result of neck
one impacting some other pathway we see
exactly the same thing if we do rip one
shrna and we see again a benefit to the
viability of matrix detached cells while
no impact while having no impact on
matrix attached cells okay so this seems
like our hypothesis that potentially
programmed necrosis is induced in matrix
detached cells that our hypothesis might
be right that potentially matrix
attachment causes the activation of rip
1 which would lead to a cascade leading
to program necrosis but we started to
think about things a little bit
differently and when we started to get
these data that I'm going to show you
now so rip 1 typically in necroptosis
will activate and phosphorylate
three which can then signal downstream
to a protein called ml KL and that
protein ml KL has the capacity to
disrupt the integrity of the plasma
membrane so those are sort of the key
they're not the only players but their
thoughts would be some of the really key
players in necroptosis so we wanted to
look at three we wanted to look at MLK l
and if you're looking you're looking
here at this gel which is again in RM CF
10a cells expressing PCL to in this case
detachment does not change the
activation or change the abundance of
rip three which is interesting very
different than rip one but doesn't mean
that that activity that protein is that
proteins activity is not so important
and you can actually do experiments
where we antagonize riff 3 with an
inhibitor GSK 872 we know that this
inhibitor is working because we can
measure the phosphorylation downstream
of ml KL you can see this here but
what's interesting is if you look at the
viability that GSK treatment has no
impact on whether these cells live or
die so it has no impact in attached
cells has no impact in detached cells
and what that tells you is that this is
something very different than rip one
that we if we inhibit rip one then you
see this fundamental difference in the
viability of matrix attached cells but
rip 3 is completely dispensable you can
inhibit its activity and really don't
have any impact on whether those cells
live or die and just to be clear we did
again I'm not going to go through all of
the the experiments we did here but we
did inhibitors of ML KL you can see this
compound NSA that I'm showing you here
on the right we did genetic knockdowns
of rip three of ML KL and in all those
cases rip 3 nm lkl are completely
dispensable you can inhibit those you
can inhibit the activity of those
proteins inhibit the abundance of those
proteins and you do not impact the
ability of those cells to live or die
when they're grown in detachment so this
leaves us with a model whereby
potentially we have a ripp kinase 1
dependent effect but a rip free or ml ko
independent effect so that got us
thinking what else could be downstream
of RIP 1 and there
a protein called pn5 this is a
phosphatase known to be localized to the
mitochondria that has been linked in
through previous studies to rip one
biology and so we started to think that
pm5 might be an interesting protein for
us to look at so we did similar
experiments where we did we look at the
abundance of bm5 what we don't see is we
see no evidence that pm5 abundance
changes in detachment but interestingly
if we do knockdowns that we do loss of
function what you're seeing here is
shRNA against PM 5 these are two
different hairpins the a and the B
hairpin we again see this significant
change in the viability of these cells
so this is done in our m CF 10a cells
you knockdown PGM v and you see this
this really fundamental difference again
only in detachment where now these cells
are surviving are surviving more
efficiently so this is very similar the
subpoena copies what we see when we
inhibit rip 1 so suggesting that
potentially they're in the same pathway
so knockdown of PM 5 recapitulates what
happens when you do rip one in vision or
if one knockdown but how do we really
know that PM 5 is downstream so in order
to ask this question we took we
generated cells that were deficient in
PM 5 you can see this here these are H
460 lung cancer cells we do shrna to get
a deficient pm5 deficient cell line and
then we mimicked attachment by over
expressing rip 1 so just explain this
again remember that detachment itself is
a signal for the induction of rip 1 and
that when you overexpress rip 1 when we
do this in attached cells that mimics
what happens when you grow cells in
detachment so you can see here on the
left h 460 cells
wild-type or vector RP lko its vector
expressing h 460 cells over expressing
rip 1 much like you would see during
detachment lowers viability that's
exactly what we would have predicted but
if you do that same experiment in the
context where you have now removed PM 5
what you see is the ability of rip 1 to
lower by a bit
is now lost and what this tells us is is
the way we interpret these data is that
rip one the ability of reforms who limit
the viability of cells requires pm5 in
some capacity and so we expanded these
studies again into a variety of other
lines and and we see again much like we
saw with rip 1 if we if we do loss of
function assays with PBM 5 we see
exactly the same thing in all of these
different cell lines we're basically in
detached cells loss of PM 5 gives you an
increased increased viability during
detachment but what is actually going on
we're really my background is really
cell biology we're interested in
understanding fundamentally what's going
on downstream of PM 5 how is it that rip
1 signaling through P gamma 5 is
ultimately causing these cells to die
and so mark got really interested in in
understanding if potentially PM 5 itself
could be altering the mitochondria and
we were sort of inspired by this idea
that PM 5 had been previously linked to
the regulation of my toffee G which is
the intracellular turnover of
mitochondria that's regulated by pink
one kinase so mark wanted to look at if
is there a relationship between rip 1
and NPM 5 and he first looked at pink
one here you're looking at pink one is
the kinase that's involved in the
induction of might Apogee again you're
looking at attached versus detached
cells you can see a significant increase
in pink worn during detachment which is
interesting and consistent with the idea
that we might be somehow inducing a my
top a G like response interestingly if
you look at that pink one and then you
treat with neck one
so remember neck one is a kinase
inhibitor for rip 1 so in this condition
you see increased viability of matrix
detached cells the other thing you see
is you start to see a a cleavage product
of the pink one protein this lower
molecular weight version and what that
what that tells you is that potentially
if you shut rip kinase signaling off
during detach
that potentially you're starting to get
some level of proteolytic cleavage of
pink one and that proteolytic cleavage
might compromise pink ones activity so
mark wanted to make sure that was in
fact the case we looked at a downstream
substrate for pink one phosphate
ubiquitin so you can see phosphate
ubiquitin levels are up at very high
levels during detachment in the control
in the ncf 10a cells expressing bcl-2
treated with the MSO but when you bring
in that rip kinase inhibitor you
significantly compromised the activity
of pink one as demonstrated by this
diminished intensity of this band so
this leaves us with this idea that you
turn on rip one and you somehow
potentially will stabilize the pink one
protein but as soon as you inhibit the
kinase activity of vert one the activity
of pink one is now compromised which
means that my top adji could be
compromised as well and I'll get to that
in a second now we did similar things
this was done in mcf Tenet's we did
similar experiments in h 460 cells we
see basically exactly the same thing and
again if you look at the mechanism for
how this happens on mark really did some
really really very nice
immunoprecipitation experiments to sort
of figure this out and what he
determined was that as a consequence of
the kinase activity of RIP 1 you get a
complex that forms between RIP 1 PGM 5
and pink one and that complex protects
pink one from being cleaved by a
protease known as par L so if you
disrupt reform with something like neck
neck one treatment then that complex
falls apart pink one is now susceptible
to proteolytic cleavage by par L which
then compromises that is is that its
activity and what the the hypothesis
would then be is that ultimately when
you regulate the stability of pink one
like this that when you inhibit rip one
that gives cells a benefit they start to
survive better this may be due to the
fact that you're inhibiting sort of a
might Apogee response by compromising
the integrity of the pink one protein
okay
but what I haven't shown you is release
all
that suggests that rip 1 is ultimately
giving you a that rip 1 is leading to a
cascade that induces my topic and that
ultimately my topic may somehow be
compromising the viability of cells but
what I haven't shown you is any assays
that actually measure my top Agyei and
again my top Oh G is the intracellular
turnover of the mitochondria in Auto
phagosome so it's analogous to otology
it's just that the cargo in the auto
phagosome ziz is the mitochondria so
what Mark did is he looked for evidence
of might Apogee first by measuring the
abundance of different mitochondrial
proteins so this is looking at Tom xx
this is an outer mitochondrial membrane
protein localized to the mitochondria
you can see that that protein detachment
is a signal for that protein to go down
again that's suggestive or indicative of
a my topic Z responses that you would be
turning over your mitochondria when you
inhibit rip kinase with the neck one
inhibitor you block this and now Tom 20
levels remain high so that's pretty
decent evidence that seems to suggest
that there is a might Apogee response
during detachment and it's connected to
rip kinase signaling here it is with
shrnas so again here is our controls on
the left you can see detachment causes
the loss of Tom 20 if you either do
shrna against rip 1 or shrna against PKM
5 you abrogate this and now tom 20
levels are maintained during detachment
so this seems to again suggest a link
between rip one big am 5 and the
induction of my Safa g mark also did
this with mt co 2 this is a
mitochondrial e encoded protein again
detachment causes this protein to go
down significantly and you inhibit rip
kinase you can see a rescue here where
that protein now maintains a higher
level so all of this seems to suggest
that detachment is a signal for turning
over or a diminished mitochondrial
abundance and that if you inhibit rip 1
you can rescue this so there's a direct
link between rip 1 signaling and my
Tophet G or the mitochondrial abundance
so then what Mark did is he looked at
the number of might of
mitochondria by might attract err and
you can see here if you start on the
left meta tracker is just a stain for
the number of the mitochondria if you
look in attach cells you can see a lot
of red you go into detachment and that
red disappears again indicating that
your mitochondria are you're diminishing
the mitochondrial number you do the same
experiment where you've knocked out or
knocked down rip one or PKM five and you
can see that detachment does not give
you that same loss of the mitochondrial
signal and here's the quantitation on
this so again what that's telling you is
the number of the mitochondria goes down
significantly as a consequence of matrix
detachment and that if you inhibit
either rip 1 or ppm 5 you can rescue
this so it again directly links this
pathway rip 1 PGM 5 to the induction of
some type of mitochondrial turnover now
do we really know that this is my Papaji
I mean again I showed you that pink one
pink one which is widely known to induce
my Java G is regulated by rip 1 I've
shown you that there's a change in the
mitochondrial number but that doesn't
directly tell you for sure that it is
the might otha G it is a my top of G
response that you're ultimately seeing
and in order to to address this we
actually went in and manipulated the
machinery involved in the execution of
my top of G so again let me show you
here these are MC of 10a cells in
control you can see that my detractors
staining that might attract there an
attachment goes down with the attachment
and you block that when you inhibit rip
one with the necro set in one compound
and then we do this in cells that have
been engineered to be deficient in h HT
g 585 is critical for the formation of
Auto phagosome x' so this is basically a
crisper cast generated line where now
they're deficient in their capacity to
undergo really any type of otology but
certainly my top adji where you could
select where you could incorporate
mitochondria into Auto phagosome x' and
you can see now that you'd not only
don't have that loss in the
mitochondrial number during detachment
but the in the treatment with neck one
completely doesn't matter anymore there
is no impact of treating with neck one
if you don't have intact
Auto
at Apogee machinery you engineer these
cells where you add back in eighty g5
and now you've restored this your meta
tracker sting signal goes down during
detachment but you treat with neck one
and you rescue this so what this tells
you is that this is a bonafide
my top a G response mitochondria numbers
are diminishing during detachment they
are rescued when you inhibit rip one and
if you don't have you don't have the
might of the my top of G here the
autophagy machinery then the ability of
rippln to regulate viability is
completely lost so we thought this was
this was a really nice way to sort of
link these changes we're seeing during
detachment to the regulation of both
riff one and two the maitake machinery
now why is it that rip one mediated my
top edgy causes cells to die this is
sort of this is something that's really
sort of interesting to us and admittedly
we still don't fully understand exactly
how this works but why is it that if you
induce cells in detachment to undergo my
top adji as a consequence of RIP 1
signaling why is it that these cells
ultimately die and we were interested in
the possibility that the induction of my
top EG may impact the levels of our OS
generating from the mitochondria so we
got these really interesting data so
this is a this is a we're using a stain
called Midas ox here which stains
reactive oxygen species specifically
coming from the mitochondria you can see
that in detachment that you see this
significant induction it might a stock
so you see high levels of mitochondrial
ro s if you inhibit rip one or PKM v
this goes this this induction of ro s is
completely lost and this is sort of
perplexing because this sort of suggests
that my toffee G itself is causing our
OS and white Apogee is typically thought
of as a cellular response to eliminate
defective mitochondria that are
themselves causing our high levels of
our OS but we're arguing in these data
suggest that the mere act of inducing my
toffee G is enough to give you sort of
an induction in our OS and again we
don't fully understand exactly why this
is the case yet
again we went back to this these
experiments where we looked at the
machinery on the my top of gr autopsy
machinery to prove that in fact it was a
consequence of my topology induction
that we were getting mitochondrial ro s
here is our control cells you can see
the induction in Midas ox staining it
with the MSO treatment you can see that
it's blocked with neck one which is
again that rif-1 kinase inhibitor but if
you get rid of ATG 5 which again is the
is a key protein involved in allowing
for the autopsy process to occur
detachment no longer gives you an
increase in in Midas ox staining and
Nick one has no impact so again that's
telling you there's a direct link
between the induction of my toffee G and
this generation of RLS now again you do
your rescue experiment you add back in
eighty g5 and you restore this and now
detachment gives you an increase in in
my toe socks that neck one can can
regulate so again I we do not claim to
have fully figured this out yet we don't
understand exactly what it is about my
top adji that leaves that leads to high
levels of ro s but it seems like there
is a fundamental link between detachment
rippln activation the induction of my
top adji and ultimately an accumulation
of high levels of ro s and that's
something we're interested and continue
to to further pursue so let me end with
one last one last piece of data here so
all of this if you take all of this cell
biology that we've talked about we've
talked about how rip kinase activation
during detachment stabilizes pink one
leads to the induction of my toffee G
and ultimately cells in detachment will
die as a consequence of this so you
might predict then that if you disable
this pathway in cancer cells that this
would enable them to more efficiently
form tumors and so mark wanted to test
this directly in a xenograft assay and
basically what he did is he generated
lung cancer cells age four 60s that were
either defective in are deficient in rip
1 or deficient in begin 5 and then
injected these into the tail vein of an
immunocompromised Mouse and we chose
this
I say because we wanted to to get an
idea of how what happens when you put
cells immediately into a context where
they are going to be forced to survive
during attachment you're putting them
directly into the circulation here you
can see on the left this is healthy lung
volume so as tumors accumulate in the
lungs this signal would go down you can
see the blue line shows you notes change
over time that's expected if you inject
H 460 cells you do get tumors forming
and you can see this over time you start
to accumulate more tumor the healthy
lung volume goes down but if you do this
in the context of rip one knockdown or
PM five knockdown that this is will be
accelerated and you get more tumor
burden is what we can predict if you
actually do ex vivo analysis of the
lungs you can see here here at the
bottom this is lungs from cells that
were from mice that received just the H
460 injection again there is tumor
forming there is tumor on these lungs
but ultimately the abundance of that
tumor the amount of that that tumor
burden is significantly lower than when
you either have the knockdown of rippln
or PM 5 and so what that would suggest
to us is that this pathway is that that
we we've been studying may impact the
viability of cells of cancer cells
during tumor progression and that
antagonizing that pathway might be a
strategy that tumor cells use in order
to in order to survive more efficiently
and we do have evidence that this is in
fact the case in patients and this is a
stat this is a study of lung cancer
patients where you're looking at overall
survival and you're ranking you're
bending into tumors that are patients
that either had low or high expression
of rip wand in their tumors and you can
see the prognosis or the you can see the
the overall survival of patients that
have low levels of rip one which went in
there by enable those those cells to
potentially survive a little bit more
efficiently that their overall survival
is actually much lower than patients who
have high levels of ripple now we're not
necessarily suggesting that that's how
that's what happens in the majority of
cancer patients rip you could
imagine a variety of different ways or
strategies that cancer cells would use
to turn this pathway off but we do think
this is at least evidence that
potentially there is a clinical benefit
to maintaining this pathway in patients
and potentially thereby allowing cells
to be killed during tumor progression
rather than them to survive obviously
this is entirely correlative but we
think this is really interesting and in
line with our hypothesis on the basis of
our xenograph data so I'll end here just
with a quick summary on just a brief I
didn't go through all of the pieces of
the mechanism and that that mark figured
out there's some of those has been
building here this paper was actually
just published a couple months ago so if
anybody's interested obviously take a
look at that manuscripts but in matrix
detached cells you have an activation of
RIP 1 you have the stabilization of pink
one which leads to the induction of my
top og there is an increase in
mitochondrial ro s which leads to cells
dying and then if you inhibit this
pathway you allow for pink one to be
proteolytically inactivated
this basically allows for this allows
for an inhibition of my top adji and
this was one of the things we do know is
this restores some of the reducing
potential in the mitochondria
particularly from ID h2 to produce nadph
and we get some sort of protection from
mitochondrial our OS we know that this
matters in vivo because you inhibit this
pathway and you can enhance it swimmer
formation in vivo and you know we're
really again we we obviously don't have
everything figured out in this case
there's still a lot of really
interesting questions that we're
pursuing but we think this is a really
exciting finding that tells us a little
bit more about about how it is that
cells survive our matrix attached
conditions and ultimately what that
means that that may have consequences
for how cells progress cancer cells
survive during tumor progression let me
just acknowledge a couple people and I'm
happy to take questions if anybody has
any I mentioned this is really just sort
of a
I've got a lot of people for my lab on
here so again I mentioned this before
mark Hawk is the grad student who led up
this study there were other people
involved mark really was the the primary
driver of this really nice
I have three other grad students right
now mattias Jordan and Lisa all will be
phenomenal have a great technician Gemma
my five undergraduate students working
with me and that changes depending on
the time of year we've had some great
collaborator in this Ralph D broodiness
play Jiang previously from his lab at UT
Southwestern for really grateful
operator Flint's project Mike Overholser
at sloan-kettering and Yin's and Monica
from his lab at Matt's team Tara Chapman
tells us he was named called Ian FIBO
study got a variety again I again I
these were some former lab members
Cassie Gorsuch also worked on this
project significantly and again a
variety of I've really been very lucky
to have such a transfer spot that I've
had so far these are some previous
undergrads that I had our sources of
funding and again I'm happy to take to
take any questions
thanks Ashley said it's a pretty nice
yeah thank you I appreciate it I have
one question like during metastasis
right name cells leave the tumor and go
to the other organs right so when when
you say like cells are released cells
get died when they're coming out from
this tumor right so I have you looked
into that aspect like what does it
different in there compared to what you
are seeing in here I think they're
they're probably ultimately related I
think that there is no question that
cancer cells when they leave primary
tumor and when they starts to travel in
the circulation bye-bye that these death
pathways are going to be important and
what I mean by that is hurting those
pathways off
so we think that through our studies as
well as a variety of other groups who
are really active in Korea that
potentially if you can find a way to
sort of interfere with their capacity to
chuck these death pathways off but that
might be in effect novel therapeutic
credit and it could happen either by
causing those cells to ultimately turn
on being weakest pathway or it could
happen by rewiring their metabolism in a
way that impacts that impacts their
ability to induce this might opposite
response so we do think those things are
related because those environments
counter that's a stressful condition
we're shutting these death pathways off
is pretty important I think I don't know
it's a very nice presentation I learned
a lot from your presentation today
I really really appreciate you taking
time and talk to us about this your work
and so do you have any like can I give
you a email out so that if it have
interested in talking to you I can do
that please Louie and I really
appreciate the opportunity to
participate here today and congrats to
you on putting together such a great
community and really making making it
easier for scientists communicate I
think this is a really great idea and
I'm just happy to be part of it so thank
you so much so you could be on our
website as soon as we are done and you
can go and watch it you can let us know
about it and good luck with your
research
thank you so much thank you I appreciate
it take care